the alcoholics dimension-hopping mad
scientist Tareq Sanchez could be called
a lot of things compassionate friendly
and filled with basic human decency are
not among them each year you don't worry
about it so what if the most meaningful
day of your life is a simulation
operating at minimum capacity over two
seasons Rick and Morty have killed
countless people destroy whole
civilizations and have just made some
pretty terrible life decisions here are
some of the worst things
Rick and Morty have ever done murdered a
bunch of bureaucrats Rick's brazen
disregard for most everything is
established in the pilot when he drags
Morty out of class to an expedition to
the mention 35c so Rick can use him to
smuggle some powerful mega seeds through
interdimensional customs and I'm gonna
need you to put them way up inside your
butthole Morty my butt put them way up
inside there as far as they can go
cheese Rick but their plan doesn't work
out
so Rick has to commandeer a portal home
while Morty engages in a shootout with
the customs officials morty ends up
killing dozens of aliens with personal
lives and loving families robots Rick
it's a figure of speech
Morty to bureaucrat I don't respect them
blew up the Siberians
did nothing people isn't the nicest way
to get secrets but you can't help but
like decide Aryans in episode 4 of the
first season after a series of
simulations within simulations the alien
scammers maneuver wreck into a situation
where he gives up the recipe for
concentrated dark matter crap that looks
okay to parts of plutonic quarks one
part caesium but as usual Rick is one
step ahead of them the whole time
there's Eiji reans try out the recipe
and the blow up their entire ship which
would have been bad enough but of course
the show adds this little tidbit right
before they all die and listen I'm sorry
for yelling earlier I couldn't ask for a
better staff I love you guys and I love
all your family man it's like Rick can
only destroy things with families
Cronenberg to the world Rick's done some
pretty bad things but leaving an entire
reality and the grip of horrible
suffering might be one of the worst
after inadvertently making the entire
population of Earth 4 violently in love
with Morty Rick fixes the problem with a
little science
where we gonna do it's gonna be fine
Morty relax I whipped up an antidote
it's based on praying mantis DNA but not
turns everyone into bud monsters Rick
fixes the problem with better science
koala mixed with rattlesnake chimpanzee
cactus shark Golden Retriever and just a
smidge of dinosaur should add up to
normal humanity that's when the episode
gets dark
Rick's new serum also backfires but to
Rick and Morty stick around to fix
things
nope they just abandon everyone in the
world to a lifetime of suffering and
take the places of their dead selves and
an alternate reality Rick what about the
reality we left behind what about the
reality where Hitler cured cancer Morty
the answer is don't think about it
created a bruh Dolph Winkler the first
season finale introduced a ton of new
awesome characters like a bird person
and squanchy a good place for me to
Squatch around here watch it you can
Squatch wherever you want man me casa es
su casa da all right but the strangest
guests at the party has to be a bird of
winkler a mutants creation with the
combined DNA of Abraham Lincoln and
Adolf Hitler who was abandoned by his
father / God Rick the existential pain
of this guy is just off the charts and
wrecked being wrecked
couldn't care less even when Abe Rodolfo
lincoler sacrifices himself and think
motional and people start crying Rick's
only got one thing to say at least he
didn't die in vain he got these crystals
and these babies just saved this
lame-ass party hold up a doctor because
there's nothing like sacrifice and
emotional torment to kick off a party
right abandoned Jerry forever
the Cronenberg episodes last the
original version of Jerry in a mutated
hellhole but Rick wasn't done with the
guy in season 2 episode 2 Rick drops him
off at the facility that basically
amounts to a giant daycare but Jerry's
dozens of versions of Jerry wander
around in various states of confusion
and destruction waiting to be picked up
again but one room contains all the
juries who were completely abandoned by
their ex and Morty's these are the
Jerry's who's Rick's and Morty's never
came back
[Music]
these guys are stuck in a nursing home
on an alien planet forever well-composed
oppressing created and destroyed a
universe rigs got a pretty heavy god
vibe going throughout the series and
nowhere is that more apparent than in
his choice of car battery which contains
an entire universe whose sole purpose is
to well power his car whole planet
sitting around making your power for you
that slavery it's society they work for
each other Morty basically Rick's car
battery contains an entire civilization
of sentient intelligent beings who
happen to be so intelligent they make
another battery with its own micro
universe and Rick have zero problem
smashing that battery to pieces killing
the civilization inside guys johnathan
is massive beast oh you monster yep
that's all of these guys and their
families smashed out of existence by the
time Rick and Morty escaped the car
battery all the creatures inside know
that they're slaves and they have no
choice but to keep their meaningless
existence going
why don't you think what's going to
happen I was going to have to toss a
broken battery or the battery wouldn't
be broken is this guy the worst yep
almost but there's more because there
was also the time Rick and Morty
slaughtered innocent aliens in season
two's penultimate episode
Rick and Morty stop for windshield wiper
fluid on a planet which is about to
commence of the festival you've been
able to sustain world peace because you
have one night a year where you all run
around robbing and murdering each other
without consequence that's right what
it's like the purge Morty that movie the
purge Rick convinces Morty to stick
around and watch the purge and they try
to save a girl and it's all backfires
when they get caught up in the middle of
the mayhem hardest-working liver in the
galaxy morning now it has a hole in it I
hope it was worth it I was just trying
to do right yeah well that's not really
the theme of tonight's party
refunds in the end they strap on a pair
of powered battle suits and go to town
on the townfolk killing just about
everyone really going for it over there
huh I think things those people were
just training
I'll give it put a deadly bacteria in
ice cream if there's anything RIT cares
about it Justin Lee isn't Derek and we
got solid proof of that in season 2
episode which opens with Jerry in an
alien hospital projectile spewing toxic
vomit so for that stuff it'll stain if
it gets on your clothes and it'll send
you into a murderous rage if it gets in
your eyes or mouth which happened
because Rick's towards some mutants
bacteria in a pint of Cherry Garcia ice
cream and because of that Jerry comes
close to getting castrated so his
genitals can serve as another guy's
heart transplant but in the end of
terrible a guy as rich may be one thing
for sure he always has the situation
under control
granite and
ah why
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love thing
[Music]